asian influenza spreads rapidly it can
strike you and your entire family at the
same time but it doesn't have to happen
if you and your family are vaccinated
against asian influenza get this
perfection in time see your doctor or
health department now
vaccination is your only protection
against asian influenza be sure you and
every member of your family have this
protection in time once the disease
strikes your community it is too late
for vaccination see your doctor or
health department now
for the first time in history we are
forewarned of a possible epidemic you
can help prevent the spread of Asian
influenza and protect the health of your
family by vaccination against asian
influenza don't wait see your doctor or
health department now
if you need to be on the job every
working day you can't afford any
unnecessary illness asian influenza can
make you too sick to work don't risk it
take the time to be vaccinated against
asian influenza and stay on the job full
time